aaj kuch me llamo labor skeptic oh hello
dr. little sketch them debated taiyar it
important to start on it for no okay
just company for not clear you know next
on temple in the meantime put it haha it
Sanjaya oh he boo-booed oriini miss
kamalini sort of equally good evening
people in your chocolate in a bowl mrs.
Cole after a poder de Jackie on in salad
it law do next up there Tina order good
enough Athena it 24-yard Basilica some
leaves are facing you also the way
Taylor Barden University dalliance hey
Shannon commemorated taco 0 or as a
whole okay then well no in panic and to
stucco brick dated like up and okay
you put it off to take backup you peel
it and you wrap it on the bread
convention in Turkey they lie that loud
grand mal I i will show you how to do
this okay if you are making bruschetta
for a lot of people instead of grabbing
the garlic you may want to just cut some
pieces of garlic and miss Cole era
contigo daleney salad audio leave it in
the fridge for everyone else it takes
the taste of the garlic and then remove
the carpet for those people may not be
so happy okay hmm and this is our auntie
possible not on the bus stop one quick
Young Money ingredient it fails let me
love Simon Ramirez sonic alla parmigiana
hello Camela prepare young bees anja
laval a lick Leland salmon if I yarlen
effective sake yes maximum 1 centimeter
thick better less you do the conversion
8 inches ok and then you remember since
we don't want the melanzana to Beecher
you're going to put them in the sink in
a bowl with some salt and let the open
tray and then wash them very well
driving ok that's there are cool slices
or just it's like
ah ok then when when we've done this
preparation lick [ __ ] on watch it we're
going to bring them before know Vinny
before never 10-4 in the meter petite a
preparar una salsa Commodore preparate
in sofrito con la yo no soy yo estaba
banando a poem about your personal life
yo i'm going to use on big topic this
time it was after a scuffle in the
saturn moon toro a point with it a solid
a respected simulated with your casino a
[ __ ] okay and then i will tell you how
to assemble everything because the idea
is to make layers of Jubilee pomodoro
limit and sunny the y after black smoke
Sarah and love it let me jump and you
want to keep some leaves of Basilica
pentavalent sonic
cleanin da cultura last dish prep area
malos fixity no in bianco what does
pizza t know me II know it's positive
message to but literally it means like
the little broken feel excited means to
break the rhythm broken food ping allora
preparate is sofrito kona people chipola
sea contigo a la will let you fold left
corner c cone something wrong see the no
se SI liquor all day look out look out
that the particular sofrito fine I'm
June jetta black ass ebony attention
performance would see the boy
illustrated up a sweat lasagna Adam
cella Carlin we wanted to like roast be
comin round at outside a pipe Osama jun
Ji Hoon Dada Dada if rosemary don't know
son Lauro babies la patate stop Oh Joe
in watching fujiyama law spezzatino
nikla pentola aprecio nay ba ha detto
school ah ah ah oh kavitha boyfriend a
la venta de Bracy onan gracias a la mala
penta s yonan podcast / cucina pew
rápidamente faster without FB hours
where of young family vote on tatami LOL
my paper at the co nen co LaPenta la
passione pizzonia ajuns la TARTA aqua
avenia tanta molta i will show you how
much okay and then we will start cooking
it's Aquino a cute rd top afterwards add
some jamo flip a topic ok Simeon Lee
McCarthy con la Carlin give it home ok
come here mashed okay bronty vente see
ya
I'll never forget this Abby amo you
funny stuff
yeah they stop me llamo y como de lima
before pena blanca
oh yeah yeah yeah
you plannin
veena to see about it noodles money
I'm in Camelot etc stop hakushi open a
desk so sorry yeah sumitomo daughter boy
shut me down buzzy look a banana well
try starting time players and tillery
check w knowledge he's on a freak
Jarrett keep fri libel and salmon egg
worn on a basilica cinco de yada saara
Stanton ando por ay SI possono boo sorry
Sonya daya this on CL true
okay LG while your coochie nodded veloce
mentor a laura mckee amo pocket real and
honest mobile venom one of cefotetan
quattro she was stocky layer through two
minutes on sassy like tacos hear from
you Wow mr. Walker como si nada potato
cuz I'm a potato but that's okay see
Sarah I don't you forgotten what I
forgot to tell you for that a total to
see ya to do good
in this masculine
member